Alhamdulillah.
Continuing
in
from.
[Silence]
So this chapter in the chapters of
prayer regarding the times of salah this
chapter is dedicated to
the sunnah.
It is a very
seldomly practiced sunnah in mass or
in j but it is common and can be common
when a person prays alone or in his
home. And that is the sunnah of delaying
past the beginning of its time
to
the very end of the first half of the
night
or the first third of the night.
As long as it does not pose a difficulty
for the people doing so.
foram.
[Silence]
Muslim
and so
narrates that the prophet sallall.aii
Wasam once made very late. So late that
the majority of the night had gone had
passed by. So late that it became very
dark in Medina. You know what does
that mean it became very dark? Well
number one
the
horizons are very dark. Number two you
know people are usually awake. They have
their little lights in their in their
respective homes, but as time goes on,
this one goes to bed and that one goes
to bed and this one goes to bed until
there's no more light. Everyone's
sleeping really. She says, "And to the
point that people that were waiting in
the masid
for the prophet sallallah.aii wasallam
to lead them in also fell asleep.
And then he emerged and he led them in
as he then turned to the companions
after finishing salah and said, "I have
just or we have just prayed at the best
at the peak of its time.
Had it not been a difficulty upon my
nation, I would have prescribed this
time." However, you know, it's a
difficulty to wait that long to
interrupt sleep especially people are
going to wake up for at night, people
are going to wake up for fud etc. So it
becomes difficult and the sunnah was
that the companions would usually make
and remain there in the masjid. They
would stay there. He encouraged them
that if you do not have something
categorically necessary to do then just
stay in the masid until which is why
another reason that we see that one of
the longest prayers he would make is
and then one of the shortest prayers is
of the audible prayers. So he'd make
long
and then after that people would make
sunnah etc. By the time a person has
made
for a lengthy amount of time
done thear
done
the salah
is at the doors. So they would wait they
would wait until he would come out and
lead them in salah. But he wouldn't come
out every night at the same exact night
at the same exact time. Sometimes he
would come out earlier, sometimes later.
And if he had something to deal with, he
would deal with it and then lead in lead
them inev because as we will hear, he
highly discouraged any goings and
comingings and any conversations
after
the sunnah is that when a person makes
salah,
they go home and go to sleep. This is
the sunnah. Unless there are a couple of
things that are exempted from this
general sunnah.
And so the next chapter is the
discouragement
of the prophet sallall.aii Wasam
that a person sleep before is before
making is or that a person have
conversations and talks after.
Now does this mean that after we make
everyone is silent as we scurry to our
cars and leave without saying anything
to anyone? No, that's not the meaning of
the narration. The meaning of the
narration is hanging out, right? In
colloquial terms, hanging out. , you
know, they say, chillaxing after
come over. We have a card game. We have
a this game. We hang out and talk until
the wee hours of the night. This is
something which is discouraged. And so
the prophet sallall.aii Wasallam
would discourage sleeping before Aisha
and having extended conversations
and
you know company over and so forth.
After
forch.
[Silence]
for.
So he mentions here two narrations
regarding this point which is the
disapproval
of the prophet sallall.aii Wasam of
sleeping before making Aisha and
conversing for extended times for
extended periods of time after without
there being some need to do so.
Something happens something out of
the ordinary it's not customary that
needs to be dealt with. Sure. The
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam had
many of his or some of his war meetings
after
in private because the hypocrites would
not come for
or would seldom come for and it was
dark. And so he was able to meet with
his generals after
in the cover of dark. And then he would
make dua and Allah would provide each of
them a heavenly lantern that would guide
them to their homes after they were
completed after their talks were
concluded. And so if a person has a need
after a
however the norm is that
triggers nighttime or sleep routine. And
so Abu Ba said that the that the
messenger of Allah
wasallam used to discourage sleeping
before and conversing after. And this
narration is in Bkari Muslim and Annis
narrates that we waited for the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam one evening to lead
us in
to the point that the first half of the
night was almost upon us. And then he
exited from his home and he prayed and
led us in prayer after which he turned
to us and said. So now he is talking he
is addressing them. Right? So we take
from this that
seeking knowledge after is exempt from
this rule. Right? This is where the
scholars take this from. And then he
addressed us and said indeed the people
generally have prayed and gone to sleep
but you all are waiting here for and you
are in salah as long as you are waiting
for salah. So this entire time that you
were waiting you were actually counted
as being in salah as long as you were
waiting for salah. This narration is
also in Bkari Muslim.